ora fuori
benvenuti e sono i tasti da oggi il
nuovo attore a di natale andremo da
babbo natale ma c'è qualcosa che non
quadra
ma come sempre sarà una storia con tanti
colpi di scena mi raccomando lasciate un
bel mobili lasciata sotto prima di
evitare perché devi covo di preti pop
corn e iniziamo subito con la nostra
storia serata l'ex i club
che succede avevo dalle scarpe strategia
forse solo per pattinare sì è vero
eccoci qua siamo nell'anno cervello a di
natale
chissà cosa succederà in questa storia
se non avete visto le scorse storia dote
vederle dopo questa perché sono super
divertenti allora dove si inizia rock
blues espresso ecco dobbiamo tregua dai
sbrigati andiamo
ok è così
sperano di natale che bello scegliamo un
posto così prima di mettere i giochi di
vediamo cosa disse dice conductor ha
quindi lui e controllo era il treno a
greta dc giusto allora io mi sono seduto
sto aspettando il pranzo non penso che
arriverà il pranzo
christmas express dove siamo è una cosa
normalissima il rischio buon natale a
tutti dice buon natale ho messo fuori un
po di latte e biscotti per babbo natale
eccoli qua non mangiare tubi tale
pensavo di essere io babbo vitale a
babbo natale non è nemmeno reale parlava
da te
ragazzi a volte le cose più reali della
vita sono cose che non possiamo vedere
ora se non andiamo a letto presto babbo
natale non verrà dai andiamo prima che
evitare mangi la casa sta trovando che
succede è questa già inizia con lo
sapevo che dovevo mangiare subito i
biscotti cosa sta succedendo là fuori
dico io
ok abbiamo la massa premi uno per
prenderla andiamo a controllare disse ok
siamo fuori ma siamo usciti dal treno
quindi eravamo ancora nel treno primi
gruppi a bordo prossima fermata al polo
nord noi siamo ancora arrivati al polo
nord
quindi dobbiamo risalire sul treno che
cos'è questo presso il treno sbrigati
questo ero blocks express
andiamo a vedere babbo natale al polo
nord ma come si fa a salire a prima
porta non lo so dovremo andare a chain
maciej john google translate questa è
un'opportunità una volta nella vita per
voi ragazze voi ragazzi vi
dirò se mamma e papà si svegliano mentre
i genitori cosi noi prendiamo il treno
ha fatta ma soprattutto stiamo andando
da babbo natale con una mazza in mano
ebbene si sa mai mette che non vuole
sganciare i regali
benvenuto a bordo prima di continuare ti
darò i biglietti d'oro wow non devi
perdere non devi perdere questo non sarà
in grado di tornare con noi no la
domanda non mangiare il biglietto
voi ragazzi deve essere freddo e deve
essere freddi e allora una fetta di
cioccolata calda
godetevi una tazza di cioccolata calda
oh che bello speriamo ci si sente non lo
sapessero tutti gli chef guarda
quanto la migliore grazie a palata
riscaldate con una deliziosa sta a non
credevi prendere
così c'è la tazza di cioccolato ok
grazie sto perdendo la mia sacco rata
studio è qui dietro di te guarda a è
così ma scommetto di cioccolato e
ambiente nonché di tutto portone era
delizioso grazie a certe ecco scusate
ragazzi sembra che abbiamo colpito
qualcosa ma non intendo le cose strane
andiamo a vedere cos'è ma x che va i
tuoi
capitolo anche la maggioranza eccoci qua
eccolo bobone do loro bambini tanto
malvagia e babbo natale cattivo
cattivo ma c'è un volante gigante su
quella su quella renna e babbo natale
andiamo al suo laboratorio
non so se possiamo fidarsi scusate
ragazzi
nessuno è permesso entrare dal polo nord
questanno madama noi siamo arrivati qua
a porta così signore perché non mi è
stato detto questo dice il direttore
d'orchestra perché ho rapito ballare
tutti i ragazzi saranno miei dottori
mi assicurerò che il natale sia rovinato
per ogni bambino del mondo ma no quindi
ha sostituito babbo natale con bambini
veloci tornati sul treno
non così in fretta non bond
ok mi ha colpito dobbiamo pensare
a che cosa che cosa brutta poverina
sei morto
no vabbè sono morta stato per colpa
della renda non è possibile non renda
misto inseguendo
dai sbrigati sono già sul treno il treno
sta andando non mi tiro testare loyos
senza di voi non ho voglia rimanere da
sola in questo treno di ritorno di avevo
paura di rimanere da sola con questo
conductor cosa è successo a babbo natale
babbo natale malvagio ha conquistato il
polo nord
dovremo andare sentirlo dobbiamo
arrivare al polo nord se non ci sarà non
si sarà natale nessun regalo per il
mondo se non sconfiggiamo il babbo
natale cattivo dobbiamo vederci
arrivarci in fretta quanto ancora siamo
in procinto di arrivare così penso che
questo sia il polo nord
questo è fino a che il treno ci porta ok
può essere così è tornato
dobbiamo andare a piedi quindi ma eccoci
qua al polo nord all'ingresso del polo
nord vediamo che bello perché si sono
due buchi
2009 sembra che babbo natale malvagio
abbia creato un buco trappola
dobbiamo scegliere il foro giusto per
saltare o no quale se ergo
tra questo
tool quale segni ma loro sono andate di
qua io ho scelto questo ok proviamo si è
però giusto per fortuna è troppo
arrotolato io dico guarda c'è la
fabbrica di babbo natale ha pregato il
babbo natale siamo questi vicini che
possiamo camminare
io non ho capito a si è rotto il
ghiaccio vedi o non dobbiamo stare
attenti non cadere giù superare i bear
daddy ghiaccio
6 tempo sbrinato
attento non cadere morto ma battigia
caduta in queste storie di robles quando
fuori bisogna comprare i robot
ok ho dovuto spendere un po d'ironia
albe non sono arrivata da esprime 14
tempo
non vi fa il treno ormai canzone siamo
passati prendiamo la mazza essere pronti
mi piace il mio outfit natalizio a se vi
state chiedendo ma come siamo nel
periodo di natale senza maniche corte
perché il suv ancora con il botto sa
molto ma come centro voleremo esegui mi
resta basso è pazzo e dove sta il
conduttore il villaggio di natale questo
posto è vuoto non vedo neppure vero dove
sono finiti tutti
sono probabilmente blu chiusi in una
stanza con il vero babbo natale ok
cerchiamoli presto dobbiamo andare a
cercarli a salvarli ok entriamo in tutte
le case e cerchiamo se c'è babbo sempre
abbiamo un mucchio di bambini cattivi
che non ascoltano e colomba è stata
sopra ho detto nessun visitatore al polo
nord
ma santa malvagia ora muori
vista mare ma non è detto con piscina
a solo 2 dai un anno eliminata anche al
risparmio tanto
mai avrei pensato che in questa storia
di kata e dovevamo colpire vero che le
sue remi e malvagie non combaciano con
la nostra forza wow roma guarda credo di
vedere babbo natale che li conosci li
legato io posso fare subito e andiamoci
arrivato a lavorare ma le rapine eccole
quale questo questa cosa sprechiamo c
conosco un modo per arrivare attraverso
la fabbrica presente su
dove ci sta portando ad esse sono capito
la storia ti fosse il problema vincente
guardate che bello ma che rischia di
regali attenta che tu hai pochissima
vita ma io dove regali passano la slitta
di babbo natale wow
questa dovrebbe portarci nella stanza di
babbo natale state attenti andate piano
ok quindi ci faremo trasportare nei post
regata ho visto salta qua non farti
prendere dalla linea rossa
ok ci siamo
noi ce l'ha fatta
lasciatemi piace per consolazione di
tutti i robot che soffre da per questa
storia mi piace qui io sono passato se
babbo natale legato quadrati e spesa
atto ad arrivare alla perché quando
proprio spendi roba è come questo sono
qui sono qui poi sono tutti a trovare
tutto lo stage di giri mi dovresti
vedere ti vedo norme e vitale sono più
di tronare alla prova liberare babbo
natale ma babbo natale non ha gli occhi
e per cui non so cosa gli sia successo
non si muove non ha gli occhi dei
bambini siete qui per salvarmi la stiamo
barberi ma va bene babbo natale noi non
ti lasceremo mai abbiamo bisogno che
salvi il natale ma quel babbo natale 1
maggio allegato mi ha legato a questa
sedia trova delle forbici per le carni
ok sbrighiamoci prima che scada il tempo
dove saranno costiamo tutte le scatole
un altrove bravo by trader lega lo siete
come si fa a prendere nessun rispetto
non riesco a prendere atto grazie mille
ha detto tu riesci a prenderle no al
abbiamo dobbiamo riprenderci la mia
slitta e renne per riavviare il
controllo ok forse ce l'abbiamo fatta a
salvare babbo natale forse ci starà ora
lo scontro epico babbo natale il
malvagio bar dal malvagio e sul tetto la
tua corsa e sopra una buona tale
malvagio arrenditi e basta non andrò
giusto giù senza combattere
eccolo già presa altro 2 a casa era di
matt ha
questo renda malvagio mi sto perdendo
tutta la vita viene eliminato una dove
l'altra questi qui
[Musica]
o
no
eccomi 16 6 se non si ma che ha comunque
fatto va bene va bene vento tu mi
arrendo sto forse
nessuno mi ha mai regalato regali di
natale crescendo
volevo solo vedere come ci si sente
immagino che non lo saprò mai va bene
rubati tutti scusa e non è giusto
poverino è per quello che è diventato
cattivo ma sono sempre abbiamo fatto
ragazzi abbiamo salvato il natale dice
babbo natale niente bambini tu hai
salvato il natale
ogni bambino del mondo ora può ottenere
i propri regali ora insieme illuminiamo
l'albero di natale ok possiamo decorarlo
vediamo
che bello
bellissimo anche questa città di natal è
bellissima grazie a te ogni bambino si
godrà il natale quest'anno ora voi
ragazzi andate a letto devo consegnare
dei regali e a noi infatti e buon natale
a tutti ea tutte le ragazze anche i
nostri di regali abbiamo preso il bel
natale come
o dalla guardate però qua dice che
possiamo diventare una renna
oppure essere il conduttore cosa non lo
so è babbo campania e anche il razzo
scarpe ok abbiamo deciso di provare un
altro gioco che simulatore di babbo
natale quindi ecco vitale non so cosa
dobbiamo fare forse dobbiamo noi
distribuire regali bello vediamo se
capiamo allora abbiamo pescato sappiamo
abbiamo una valigia hanno un regalo
anch'io di regali cappello funziona lo
slittino
la
lite esplosa una slitta volante siamo
anche noi come babbo natale si sa quindi
dobbiamo considerare sono i più strani e
io sono incastrato qui aiutami sono sono
a casa
vabbè io vado a consegnare i regali
guarda c'è qualcuno là sopra forse babbo
natale e non è stata l'iva non vola
sotto in alto allora riproviamo bisogna
prendere per dare più velocità
ecco cos'è qualcuno non conosco
la mia non mi ama la mia fritta ok sono
riuscite a cadere su un tetto ora
proviamo a mettere i regali come babbo
natale ripasseranno dal camino vediamo
sono associato competenti regali
sono tantissimi atti veneto forze ho
riempito proprio tutto di regali saranno
felicissimi forse sentono sale da
biliardo
che ho riempito anch'io di regali per il
posto di chivu che se sei qua la chiuse
un'altra città grandissima avremmo forse
dobbiamo andare lì a consegnare i regali
andiamo a vedere
[Musica]
ok sto arrivando alla città che bello
polare bello peccato che mi mancano le
renne vuole volere m vediamo dove
potremo consegnare i regali
troviamo quattro qua non sono legato
soltanto sott'acqua
aiuto no non la topina se fossero caduta
aiuto solo poche città strana forse
questo gioco non hanno finito di di
svilupparlo perché c'è qualcosa di
strano mancano tutti beve tre essere di
bordo nathan e borgonovo vt aggiunto
anche provato il simulatore di babbo
natale la stato bel mi piace ora vi
lasciamo con angelica seguì cliccare per
vedere inoltre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite buona visione